[Music]
so probably the last place that you
think about hope and optimism existing
is in prison right but in the last 10
years of working there I've come to
realize that all humans possess these
things they just need a little coaxing
sometimes and in June 2006 the actors
gang theatre company started an
experiment we decided to take the Sunday
night workshop we do with our whole
company into prison to work with non
actors to see if well what kind of
effect our style of theatre would have
on them so the style of theatre be
working is a really bastardized version
of the Italian tradition of commedia
dell'arte its masks white face highly
emotional physical work so we call it
the style and we took that workshop
program into prison and we're absolutely
astounded by the effect it had on these
non actors and how it started to help
them be able to heal their trauma we've
seen this approach transform present the
odds we've seen it bring down barriers
of race and separation and that has
happened through the courage of these
people of picking up the tools that
we've offered them and using those tools
to transform their emotional lives and
they found a safe space in our work to
be able to do that
and as a result we have a ten percent
recidivism rate and an 89 percent drop
in in prison infractions because these
people now know how to steal their
emotion so amazingly ask this little
engine the curb after ten years is now
in ten prisons across California as
Jessica mentioned and for me the thing
that makes me so proud is that any day
of the week there will be a student-led
program happening in a prison like right
now there is a program happening in a
prison that's led by our students and we
go and check in and support them every
six weeks
and apart from the re-entry programs
that we have which is now run by one of
our former students we employed in the
day he paroled to run that reentry
program we are also creating a program
for correctional officers who are often
as traumatized as the people that they
are overseeing if the highest suicide
rate of any job so the real secret of
this work for those of us who are lucky
enough to do it is that we get as much
if not more from the experience one of
our Judy girls told me the other day
when people come and work with her she
always thinks to herself
take off your cape and this has become
our motto now take off your cape because
we're not in the business of saving
people we're going in and making
offering them tools that we know work
and as a result changing our own lives
I've definitely become a better person
and a better actor and these people have
literally changed my life so I'm really
honored to introduce the stars of this
work the people I mean it was an idea I
I had an idea ten years ago a lot of
people have ideas it doesn't really mean
anything unless people make it happen
and these are the people that made it
happen
so I'd like to start off by introducing
Chris Tingley
[Applause]
good morning or afternoon oh good
afternoon everyone I'm Chris Bingley as
Sarah said I'm I was a returned to the
community last Friday from a 12-year
prison sentence and um most of my time
honestly there's not a whole lot of
programs inside of California prison so
I just kind of sat around and kind of
read books and tried to better myself on
my own but uh towards the end of my
sentence I think I've been doing the
actors gang about five years so yeah the
president project came in and um it gave
me a lot of tools it gave me a lot of
tools to deal with prison to deal with
myself and now that I'm out here it's
giving me a lot of tools that that I'm
using out here as well I'm using those
tools with my family at my job and just
everywhere I go um so just explain what
got me into prison is pretty much not
knowing how to manage my own emotions I
was angry growing up and I was I kept a
lot of that stuff inside of me and I
found people that were angry just like I
was and we did angry things and that's
what led me to prison and yeah I mean
getting involved with this work it
helped me to be able to express my
emotions something that I was never told
to do I just like I said it kept
everything inside of me so what this
work did is it created a safe place for
me to be able to express myself no
matter what without judgment whether it
be happy sad angry or feared because
those are the four emotions that we deal
with and it gave me a chance to exercise
those emotions that were inside of me
that I was so used to just constantly
pushing down and that I was used to just
acting out um and so uh yeah this work
gave me a lot of tools to learn how to
manage my emotions and not only that but
to just all kind of stuff from from
becoming becoming a team player to
supporting we always say in actors gang
support your brother our support the
other actor that's on stage with you you
know before you know of being involved
this kind of work it was just you know I
was kind of like a selfish person just
all by myself so it just
I'm going to be more more human to be
able to you know look in another
person's eyes and express the emotion
you know and be able to identify with
what the next person so guesswork is
it's great you know and I know it's
doing a lot for people inside as I ever
said it is breaking down a lot of
barriers people that would normally want
to fight each other and want to stab
each other their friends in there
because it's worth it builds a bridge
between different races between
different gangs all that stuff and you
know it's just like we can relate to
each other because it's worth so I'm
yeah pretty much
[Music]